why should the idea of sex outside be
exciting given how awkward scratchy
sandy or muddy it can be on a beach
halfway up a hillside or in the shady
bushes of a park compared with a
comforter cotton sheets in a sprog
mattress as so often with sex the
pleasure is psychological not physical
it's a thought that's turning us on and
the exciting idea is that we can at last
lose our normal self-consciousness and
inhibition and take our sexuality out
into the world without embarrassment
shame normally profoundly colors how we
perceive our own sexuality from early
adolescence we take great care to shield
our sexual sides from others they would
have no interest they might be sickened
we reserved our naked selves strictly
for the bedroom in the dark late at
night the biblical story of the
expulsion of Adam and Eve from the
Garden of Eden reflects this
embarrassment it isn't just a quaint
piece of theology it's a universal
account of how we've traveled painfully
from uninhibited toddlerhood to
embarrassed
adulthood but with a lover to lend us
new buoyancy we're liable to feel more
acceptable to ourselves again because
they a representative of the normally
brutal outer world have found us
desirable we acquire a background hope
that we might be able to do away with
the normal punishing rules and once
again enjoy the favors of a Zdenek
loving innocence to suggest we go
outside have sex is a touching
provocation a minor dare to imagine that
society will always have to be hostile
or indifferent to our vulnerable sexual
selves and by extension to our existence
more generally in truth the sex card do
more than express the hope for the short
list we'll encounter in the park or
behind the supermarket is at least
evidence of a defier
utopian faith that we can with our
lovers support perhaps turn the wider
world into what it's so seldom kids are
home
[Music]
you